I've talked about all of these little
details before and it really adds up to
a big story
bionomics lowering costs for Working
Families in a number of different areas
we now see inflation down for 11 months
in a row the child tax credit expanded
under Biden's American Rescue plan has
reduced the number of kids in poverty
significantly reduce child care costs no
one of these things is a miracle but all
of these little things do add up we then
had the bipartisan infrastructure bill
so we're finally going to get some of
those improvements to roads and bridges
and ports and airports airports and
Broadband it's not going to be what so
many other countries have you look at
Broadband in South Korea you look at a
train travel in Europe we're not there
we're not there we have a long way to go
but at least we're making some progress